there are many things we want to ask of
other people we want to ask for a job
for money a chance to collaborate a kiss
but generally we don't ask because of
the terror of a no
why should a no such a small and
innocuous word prove quite so painful so
hard to hear so much something we need
to avoid that we'd rather die and penury
ignored and unfulfilled than ever hear
it
it's because it's not a case of trying
not to hear a no
what we're trying to do is avoid hearing
something quite different
that we are disgusting
all of us have access to a disgusting
self-image a repertoire of all the most
broken flawed embarrassing and weak
sides of who we are
and it's precisely this self-image that
is awoken and engaged whenever people
say no to us
we're not hearing no
we'd be fine if we were we're hearing
you're an arrogant laughable jumped up
delusional clumsy repulsive pond life
no wonder we get reluctant to ask
but in truth of course others are not
remotely saying this to us they can't
guess how we're feeling inside it's not
written on our forehead and most
importantly it's not even true we've got
some tricky sides of course but so does
everyone else we're a mixture of good
and bad like everyone else we're okay we
deserve to exist
when people say no they're not thinking
about us
here is the only reason why people ever
say no and we need this emblazoned on
billboards so we don't forget it the
real reason people say no is that it
doesn't fit in with their plans they're
not thinking about your stupidest deeds
of the nicknames people called you at
school or of what you get up to late at
night that's in your head not theirs
they are just worried about their plans
we're losing out on some consoling
insights because we're failing to bring
our own experience of what we felt when
we said no to people we said no not
because we hated them we did it for an
obvious now repeated reason it didn't
fit in with our plans
but here's the key reason to try asking
we just don't know where people are with
their plans and we can be sure of this
by looking at our own experience when we
think about it there are actually a
surprising number of things that we
would theoretically give other people if
only they asked we would say yes at many
perhaps surprising points we'd be ready
to give certain people money time kisses
if they asked but usually people don't
ask because they don't know where we are
with our lives
all of us are fundamentally ignorant of
other people's plans we just can't
really tell whether others might say yes
or no because we don't have access to
their projects and visions
we're attempting to overcome our lack of
data by foreclosing in a pessimistic
direction but we should instead simply
try to get more data by asking we should
respond to ignorance with curiosity not
despair
we should remember too that we can
survive a no from a distance we feel it
would be a catastrophe if it were a no
from close up we can be sure we'd shrug
it off in three hours we're big people
now of course as small children we were
very vulnerable and perhaps adults said
no to us at key moments and it hurt and
now we're trying not to get hurt again
but the mind is slow to realize the time
we've grown we're perhaps six feet tall
now we have a bank account perhaps a car
maybe children of our own we can survive
a no
and in any case not asking is not cost
free we're avoiding the pain of
rejection but we're settling for
something that is more insidious and
just as troubling a lack of opportunity
not asking life for something means
implicitly asking it for something else
failure from the outset and this is
especially sad because life is so very
short what we should really be scared of
is not a no but of reaching our
deathbeds unfulfilled
we should ask
you